Great. So, today we're going to talk
about something called the folk theorem.
So, I'll warn you that the class today
is a a little more in the theoretical
side and then on Thursday we'll move
back to a substantive application.
And the folk theorem
in short says that in infinitely
repeated games
we often say anything can happen
if the players are sufficiently patient.
Of course, we're going to be more
precise about this. When we say anything
can happen
say a little more, what we really mean
is any outcome of the game
can be sustained as a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium.
So, maybe I'll say when I say anything
can happen, what I really mean is any
outcome
can be induced by a subgame perfect
can be induced
by a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
An example of this we saw is in the
prisoner's dilemma
the outcome cooperate cooperate could be
induced as a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium, but we showed that that was
only true if the discount factor delta
was at least 1/3.
And that's going to be a common theme
here that anything can happen if the
players are patient enough.
And that means that the discount factor
delta is large enough.
Now, of course, not literally anything
can happen. So, we'll see there are
there are some constraints on this, uh,
but today we're going to give a number
of theorems of this flavor. And I think
you can see how this question arose, you
know, last class we constructed a
special subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
that's the same cooperation.
But in a more complicated game, you keep
constructing subgame perfect Nash
equilibria and the question is well,
where does it stop?
Is there some other outcome that, you
know, could it be constructed, achieved
by some subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
or is this some fundamental barrier to
inducing that as a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium? And this theorem helps us
address that question. No matter how
many equilibria we construct, there's
still the question of are we missing
something? Is there something more? And
that's what this theorem is getting at.
The name, I should say a little bit
about the name of the theorem. It's not
very informative, folk theorem. What it
refers to is the fact that this was
intuited by game theorists in the 1950s
and 1960s. Everyone thought this was
true, but no one had given a formal
proof. So, it was described as folk
wisdom. And today in economics, people
often talk about a folk theorem to mean
a theorem of this form, but of course,
that really has nothing to do with folk.
Folk is just about the, you know, a
historical accident about, uh, about
this result.
Uh, and then in the '70s and '80s, this
was ultimately formalized. One of my
colleagues here at MIT, Drew Fudenberg,
uh, formalized a version of this theorem
in 1986 in a very famous paper.
So, let's
start, uh,
the setting for this.
Well, when you say any outcome can be
induced or anything can happen, what
we're really interested in is payoffs.
Um, so, let's, uh,
let's start with a simple example. Let's
look at the prisoner's dilemma.
And let's just recall the the basic
payoffs we had here.
We had CD CD and we had two two.
And it's going to be helpful to
visualize these pit payoffs
geometrically. So, what I want to do is
I want to plot these payoff vectors in
on a graph.
And these payoff vectors have two
components, one for each player. So,
these vectors are going to live in the
plane in in Euclidean space of two
dimensions. So, let me draw a graph over
here.
And let's see, we need to go from three
to negative one, so
let's see how my
drawing skills are.
Not perfect.
Okay. So, let's first plot two two.
So, that's going to be this point here.
Let's plot negative one three.
It's going to be here.
Three negative one.
Here. And then zero zero.
Here.
So, these are some
payoffs that we can have and
it turns out it's going to be helpful to
to connect these.
So, what we're interested in in the
prisoner's dilemma is what payoff
vectors can we achieve
with some subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium?
So, maybe I'll put the question here.
What payoff
vectors
can be achieved
by some subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium?
So, I think one of them is pretty easy.
What about zero zero?
Can we achieve this payoff zero zero
in a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium?
Well, this one's pretty easy, right? We
know there's an equilibrium where we
just always defect every period.
And if we always defect every period,
that's just repeating the stage game
Nash equilibrium. We argued last class
that was a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium and then we get the payoff
zero zero every period. So, that's
something we can achieve.
What about two two?
Can this be achieved?
So, two two is the payoff if we both
cooperate.
Well, we showed last class that if we're
patient enough, we can find an
equilibrium where both players
cooperate. But I've I've been a little
maybe, uh, sloppy here in that well, why
is that called a payoff of two two? The
way we've written it so far, suppose we
both cooperate every period.
Then
what our payoffs are technically, what
is each player's payoff? Well,
technically it's
two today
plus delta to the two tomorrow
plus delta squared times two of the next
day and so on.
Right?
And this is not necessarily two. In
fact, it won't be two. What is this
going to be? Well, we did the algebra
last class. We can factor out the two.
And then we have two times this series
one plus delta plus delta squared and so
on. And this is a geometric series and
we can compute it and what we get is two
over
one minus delta.
So, intuitively we want to say if the
players always cooperate their payoff is
two every period and we want to say
that's what their payoff is.
But the problem is the payoff they
actually get depends on delta.
And we're interested in the case of
where delta becomes very close to one,
in which case this payoff is going to
get really, really big. But it seems
weird to sort of say, well, their
average their payoff is a lot bigger
than two because two is the highest
payoff they can get in the stage game.
And the issue is that
we're missing a normalization. What we
really want to keep track of is the
average payoff, that weighted average
payoff, not the sum of the payoffs.
So, what we're going to do starting
today moving forward
is instead of looking at the sum of the
discounted payoffs, we're going to look
at the average discounted payoffs.
And the basic issue is before, what did
we do?
We computed a payoff stream by saying
payoffs are delta
or
say for player one, U1 of A1 plus delta
U1 of A2
uh,
zero.
And so on. So, before what we said is if
the action profile in period zero is A0
the action profile in period one is A1,
the action profile in period two is A2
and so on, then we said player one's
discounted payoff is just their payoff
in the first period, in the zeroth
period plus delta times their payoff in
the first period plus delta squared
times their payoff in the second period
and so on.
But the issue is that
you know,
there's kind of too much weight going on
here,
uh, and what we now want to look at
is what's called the average payoff
which means we're just going to scale
this by one minus delta.
So, the average payoff is going to be
one minus delta and then let me write
this as a summation. So, one minus delta
times the sum from T equals zero to
infinity of delta to the T U1
of AT. And maybe I'll say UI if I want
to be more general.
Why this mysterious one minus delta?
Well, it's to undo the one over one
minus delta that we had before.
So, the issue is that this is actually a
weighted average, but the weights don't
sum to one.
1 + delta + delta squared and so on
actually sums to 1/1-delta.
So, we're just going to normalize things
so that things make sense. And the way
we can see this is
if this is a constant
so let's say this is the same number UI
every period
then what we'd like is the average
payoff to just equal this number. If I
get the same payoff every single period,
we'd like my average discounted payoff
to equal that number. And we can see
that's going to work here
because this chalk is not very good.
If we plug this number in here, what do
we get? We get 1-delta
times UI bar
times the sum from T equals zero to
infinity of delta to the T.
So, all I've done is I've said if this
is a constant, let me pull it out to the
front of the summation.
And now, well we know that this series
is exactly 1/1-delta,
so we exactly get
UI bar.
So, all we've done is multiplied the
payoffs we used before by a constant.
That's not going to change anyone's, you
know, preferences. It's not going to
change whether anything is actually in
equilibrium, but it's going to make it
more convenient to keep track of how the
players are doing because we want, if
they play cooperate every period and
therefore get a payoff of two every
period, we'd like to call that a payoff
of two in the repeated game.
And we'd like that not to depend on the
discount factor.
So, here we're going to look at average
payoffs.
And we indeed see that
if the players play defect every period,
then they get zero every period. Their
average payoff is zero, and this can be
achieved as a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium.
We also know that this can be achieved
as a subgame perfect equilibrium,
cooperate every period, if delta is
large enough.
What about other payoff factors in here?
Do people have any guesses about, you
know, what about a payoff factor here?
Could I achieve that in a equilibrium?
There's no chance, right? Why? I see
people shaking their head.
It's not the outcomes.
Right. So,
in each stage game, I'm only getting one
of these vectors.
So, there's no way I can get something
up here.
And more precisely, what's happening is
if in each stage game, in each period,
I'm I'm getting one of these, then my
average payoff has to be an average of
these vectors.
And that's exactly what this this dotted
region is. So, the region in here
is exactly the collection of averages of
these points.
So, this may be a little hard to sort of
geometrically into it, but just as a
simple example, let's take this point.
This point is halfway between 0 0 and 2
2. It's the point 1 1, and I didn't draw
that very well. It should be about here.
How could I get an average payoff of 1 1
in this game?
Just, you know, without thinking about
equilibrium, yeah? Just like half the 0
half 2 2. Yeah, so if roughly if half
the time I played 0 0 and half the time
or so half the time I played defect
defect and half the time we played
cooperate cooperate, then that would
average out to 1 1. We have to be a
little careful with discounting because
if if actually if I played cooperate
here, defect here, cooperate here, it
wouldn't quite work out because of
discounting, but we could either mix or
we could be a little more careful, but
it's possible to do this.
And it turns out any point in here can
be achieved as kind of some
randomization or some weighted average
over the different payoff factors.
Okay.
So, now the question is which payoffs in
here could be achieved by some subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium? So, what we
first said is we've narrowed it down to
this shaded region. There's no way a
vector outside of this shaded region
could be achieved by a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium because it's not even
feasible.
And this shaded region
is called the feasible set.
So, these are the payoffs that are just,
you know,
they're feasible, it's possible to
achieve them as some average of these
other payoff factors.
But I argue that we probably can't get
everything in the feasible set. I think
there's some points in the feasible set
that I I don't see how we could get them
as a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
Any any thoughts? What points in here
seem seem unrealistic to you?
So, we've already gotten this point.
We've already gotten this point. What's
the point here that we could never
sustain as an average payoff of a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium?
Yeah?
One of the other two points just because
why would a player keep on playing poor
strategy?
Okay, so these points here?
I agree. And and what's your
what's your intuition for this? So,
let's focus on one of them. Let's focus
on on this point here. I have too many
arrows. Let me erase these arrows, and
let's focus on this one, okay?
So, um 3 -1. So,
player two 3 -1, yeah.
Player two wouldn't just keep on
cooperating cuz they'd just get a worse
payoff every time and they'd start to
find things instead.
Exactly. So, this seems really
unrealistic. It seems like we can't get
this because player two is getting a
payoff of -1. Right? But what if player
two just always played defect?
If player two always plays uh
plays defect, then they always get at
least a payoff of zero.
So, there's no way there could be an
equilibrium where player two is getting
less than zero.
So, in fact, we can rule out everything
below this horizontal axis.
Because anything below this horizontal
axis is giving player two a payoff
strictly below zero.
But let's look. If player two just
always plays defect, then well, they
either get three if the other player
plays cooperate, or they get zero if the
other player plays defect, but whatever
happens, they get at least zero. So,
there's no way they'd be willing to give
themselves a payoff this bad.
What about the region over here?
Yeah? By symmetry, we won't ever have uh
player one playing anything that doesn't
give them
a negative
that doesn't give them a negative
payoff.
Exactly. So, it's the same issue. Here,
it's player one who's not going to want
to do this because player one can always
play defect every period. And if they do
that, sometimes they get three.
Sometimes they get zero, but either way,
they get at least zero. So, why would
they ever play in an equilibrium where
they're getting less than zero?
So, we've kind of narrowed things down
to
this inner region which maybe I'll shade
darker.
So,
this is a subset of the feasible set.
The entire region is the feasible set,
but I've thrown out this region and this
region to get the darker region here.
And it turns out that any point in this
darker region can indeed be achieved by
some subgame perfect Nash equilibrium if
the players are patient enough.
And that's going to be the result that
we show. So, it's clear that we can't
get anything outside this region. That's
what I just argued. The hard part is
showing that we can get anything inside
this region. And that's going to be an
implication of folk theorem, but the
folk theorem doesn't apply just to this
game. It applies to any abstract game,
and that's what we're going to state
here. So, any questions? I think this is
a little more abstract than some things
we've been doing, so
um if anything about this setup is is
unclear, this is a good time to ask.
Yeah, great. There is a different
definition for the subset of the
feasible set that like we actually call
This this shaded region? Yeah. So, often
this is called and we'll do a few
different versions of um
So, let me just preface this by saying
the prisoner's dilemma is very special.
So, if you try to get intuition about
this set, you can get misled because it
happens to be certain things uh yeah,
it's a special case, but um this is
often called the set of payoffs that are
feasible and individually rational. I
don't really like that terminology, but
that's often the terminology that's
used. Yeah. So, the whole set is the
feasible set. The dark set is this is
the feasible set
together with the constraint that the
payoffs are individually rational.
And I should point out the zero here,
there's nothing magical about zero,
right? Zero only comes up because that's
what you get if you defect. Uh if you
yeah, if you defect. So, it could be
you know, it could be shifted a bit.
There's nothing magical about zero. It
just happens to be that way in this
game.
Okay.
So, now let's uh try to get to the kinds
of results
that we're interested in.
So, let's
First, let me be a bit more formal about
this feasible set.
So, let's let G
be a finite
stage game.
So, it could be the prisoner's dilemma,
but it could be something else.
And now I want to formally define what
this feasible set is. I just showed it
graphically in the example, but let's
formally define this.
So, the feasible payoff set
maybe I'll call it V of G
because it's the set of payoff vectors
V.
Well, what is it?
Um
it's
the collection of all averages
over
payoff factors in here.
So, what it is is it's the set of all
sums
>> Okay, this is a lot of notation, so
let's go through it slowly.
What is U of A?
U of A is a payoff vector that the
players get if the action profile A is
played.
So, this is an action profile.
And let's just make sure we understand U
of A, what space does that live? So,
let's say G is a finite stage game
with N players.
So, U of A, what kind of object is this?
Yeah? A vector
A vector in RN, right? It's a vector
with N components. Because U of A,
remember, this is just U1 of A
all the way up to UN of A.
So, this is a vector that lists what is
player one's payoff if the action A
profile A is chosen, all the way up to
what is player N's payoff if the action
profile A is chosen.
So, we have an action profile, we have a
payoff vector.
And now we're taking a summation, we're
summing over all action profiles.
So, just like over here, maybe we could
achieve this point as a weighted average
of this point, this point, this point,
and this point, that's exactly what
we're doing here.
We're taking an average
over these payoff vectors, we're summing
over all the action profiles
with possibly some weights.
And the weights have to be non-negative
and sum to one. So, that's what I mean
when I say P is an element of delta A.
That just means P is a probability
distribution
over A.
And the feasible set V of G consists of
all of these averages.
Okay.
Great. So, we have
that notation.
And now I think we can we're ready to
state the
form of
the
folk theorem. I just want to remind you
of one more piece of notation.
Remember that G of delta is our notation
for the infinitely repeated game
where the stage game is G and the
discount factor is delta.
Right?
So, this is the
with the stage game G
and discount factor delta.
SO, JUST A REMINDER HERE, IN GENERAL,
THE feasible set is pretty hard to
visualize because it lives in
N-dimensional space.
But in a two-player game, it lives in
the plane and it's a lot easier to
visualize. If there are three players,
we'd be um you know, in in normal space,
three-dimensional space, and then beyond
that it's kind of tricky.
Okay, so let's
state What I'm going to do here is state
maybe what I'll call is the folk theorem
template.
So, we're going to state a lot of
different versions of the folk theorem
and it's easy to get caught up in the
details of these different versions, so
I don't want to get distracted by the
details. I want us to understand just
the general structure of this theorem
and then we'll go through with some
special cases.
So, the folk theorem template is as
follows.
It says
here's the statement. Let G be a stage
game.
And now what we're going to do is we're
going to pick
a feasible payoff vector
associated to this stage game.
So, let's let V
be in V of G.
So, this means that V is a feasible
payoff vector in this game G.
>> [clears throat]
>> And then
here we're going to say under certain
assumptions, which are going to vary.
So, under certain assumptions, we're
going to get the following conclusion.
Well, what do we want?
We want to
achieve V
as the outcome of some subgame perfect
equilibrium whenever the the players are
sufficiently patient.
So, we're going to say under certain
assumptions,
Well, what does it mean to say they're
sufficiently patient? Well, we just need
delta to be large enough, right? So,
there's going to be some cutoff delta
and we want delta to be larger than that
cutoff. So, under certain assumptions,
there exists
delta bar
in 01.
So, this is going to be our cutoff level
of patience.
And we're going to be interested in what
happens when delta is larger than this
cutoff. So, there exists a cutoff delta
bar
such that
for all delta greater than delta bar.
So so far, I think it's kind of mathy,
but we really haven't done anything.
We're just saying for all as long as the
players are patient enough.
Formally, there's some
number, maybe it's .7, maybe it's .3,
and we're going to say as long as the
discount factor delta is larger than
that, what happens?
What we want is we want V to be induced
by some subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium.
So,
the game
G of delta
has
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
that yields payoff vector V.
So, we're going to talk later about what
these certain assumptions are, but I
just want us to understand at a high
level what the theorem's saying.
We fixed our stage game
and we fixed our vector that is
feasible. So, this is some vector that
lives in this set over here.
And what we want to conclude is that as
long as the players are patient enough,
so as long as delta is high enough,
if we look at the infinitely repeated
game G of delta, so this is the
infinitely repeated game where we play
the stage game G every period and the
discount factor we use is delta.
In that game,
there exists
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
that yields V. What do I mean by that?
Well, in the subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium, we can compute what
actually happens. There's going to be
some sequence of action profiles that
are played every period and we can
compute what payoffs every single player
gets from that equilibrium. And we want
those payoffs to exactly be V.
So,
let's just to make sure we see
I think this is a bit abstract.
We showed a version of this, a special
case of this uh last class. So, last
class,
we looked at the prisoner's dilemma
and we looked at V equals 22.
And what we showed is that
uh or an implication of what we showed
last class is that we could achieve V
equals 22
as a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
for delta large enough. What was the
value of delta bar
that we
established last class? Do you remember?
So, we showed sort of a special case of
this. For the particular choice of V
equals 22, what we did last class
implied this. What was the value of
delta bar that we could use?
Yeah? 1/3. 1/3, exactly.
What we said is
in the infinitely repeated prisoner's
dilemma with discount factor delta, as
long as delta was at least 1/3, there
was a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium
in which the players always cooperated.
And when they always cooperated, the
payoff vector that they got, the average
payoff vector, was indeed 22.
The folk theorem goes a lot more along
beyond that because it looks at any
feasible vector V, not just the
particular one 22,
and it applies not just to the
prisoner's dilemma, but to any game G.
Right?
Now, just to make sure we're on the same
page here, I put in brackets here under
certain assumptions.
We certainly need some assumptions.
So, why would this theorem How do we
know this wouldn't be true? What if I
covered up these certain assumptions
and we just look over here
at our discussion before, why would the
theorem be false without further
assumptions?
Do you remember what we we showed there
were some feasible points that couldn't
be achieved?
Right? We already showed that
a point down here
and a point up here could not be
implemented by any subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium. So, it must be the case
that those points
are going to violate whatever these
certain assumptions are that we're going
to put in here.
And then we're going to consider a few
different classes of these assumptions.
All right. So, let's now
try to do a few different versions of
the folk theorem.
So, the way this is kind of developed is
there are
I want people to be able to read this,
so let me uh
let me just leave this here and start a
new board.
So, we want to be able to see this.
So, let's go here.
So, generally, if we make really strong
assumptions,
then the theorem's going to be easier to
prove, but it's not going to get us as
far. And the way the, you know, kind of
the theory has developed is over time
these assumptions have been weakened and
weakened to make the theorem stronger
and stronger, but then that means the
the arguments are often more complex.
So, we're going to start with a really
easy version.
And this is going to be the called the
Nash
reversion folk theorem.
And this one we can we can prove pretty
easily.
So, what is the certain assumptions that
we're going to need for this version?
So, the assumptions are
So, these are going to be assumptions
about the game G and about this payoff
vector V.
And our assumption is going to be
there exists
a Nash equilibrium,
maybe I'll call it ANE
of G,
such that
VI
is greater than UI
ANE
for all players I.
So, we know that we're not going to be
able to achieve every payoff vector V.
We need some restrictions on this payoff
vector V. This is one restriction we
could have.
We say
our theorem is going to be true if we
have the following assumption.
There exists some Nash equilibrium ANE
of the stage game G,
such that every player I gets strictly
higher payoff under V
than they do under that Nash
equilibrium.
So, let's try to This is a little
abstract.
Let's apply it here.
If we apply this assumption to the
prisoner's dilemma, what what set will
we get? What will be the set of Vs that
are feasible and also satisfy this
assumption?
You want to say? Well, let's let's go
through it. In the prisoner's dilemma,
we know what the Nash equilibrium is.
What is the Nash equilibrium of the
prisoner's dilemma?
DD, right? They both play D.
So, in that context, if they both play
D,
then what does each player get in that
Nash equilibrium?
Zero, right?
So, in the context of the prisoner's
dilemma, this assumption says
we need VI
to be strictly greater than zero for
every player I.
So, notice that this assumption exactly
gives us the darkly shaded region up
here.
Because the set of feasible Vs that
satisfy this assumption are exactly the
Vs that are strictly greater than zero
here and strictly greater than zero
here, and we exactly get this shaded
region. So, now we see uh that this
assumption will rule out
these kind of bad points over here.
All right. So, now let's see if we can
give a proof of the theorem under this
assumption.
Uh let me
start a new board.
Okay.
So, let's give a proof
of the Nash reversion,
which I'm kind of giving away how we
prove it, folk theorem.
And proving it in general is a bit
tricky, so let's simplify things. Let's
look at the special case
where V, this payoff vector,
is equal to U of A star
for some action profile
A star.
So, in general, V might be only
achievable by some lottery over action
profiles, and then we have to worry
about mixing, and it gets a little
tricky. So, let's just focus on
a payoff vector V
that is achieved by some action profile
A star.
And let's just understand what we want
to prove here.
So, our assumption
is that there's some Nash equilibrium
that gives each player I strictly lower
payoffs than
what they get under this vector V.
And what we want to show
is that there's some subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium
that yields this vector V, at least if
the players are patient enough.
So, we want to say that as long as the
players are patient enough, we can
construct a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium of the repeated game that
delivers this payoff vector to the
players.
So, what we need to do is we need to
construct
an SPNE.
Well, we want to construct an SPNE
that gives this payoff vector to the
players. Well, the easiest way to do
that is if we just play A star every
period.
So, what we want is to construct an SPNE
that induces the outcome A star every
period.
If it induces A star every period, then
certainly
the players are going to get U of A star
every period, and therefore the average
payoff vector will certainly be BV. So,
then we'll be done if we can show this.
Um
Now, this may not
work unless delta's large enough, so
we're going to have to be a little
careful here, but how Does anyone have
any ideas?
This is the only thing we know.
So, how could we use this fact to try to
construct our SPNE? Any Any thoughts
here?
And maybe the name Nash reversion is a
bit of a hint.
So, let's just think through it
intuitively.
We want the players to play A star every
period. The problem is that A star is
not necessarily a Nash equilibrium of
the stage game.
So, it may be that when we're trying to
play A star, some player could deviate
and strictly increase their payoff
today.
So, we have to have some way to
discourage that by punishing that player
if that player deviates.
Any ideas about how we could punish
them?
Yeah?
Revert to the earlier Nash equilibrium.
There you go. It's right in the name.
Revert to Nash, right?
So, what this tells us is that this Nash
equilibrium is going to be a punishment.
It's a punishment because it gives a
strictly lower payoff to every player.
So, here's our strategy profile.
Well, first,
we we just all play A star until someone
deviates.
So, I'll say each player I
plays Well, A star is an action profile,
so player I is going to play their
component of that action profile, right?
Is going to play AI star
until someone deviates.
So, if you remember, the formal way to
write down a strategy is to define all
the histories and and look at this
function S, and it's a real mess, so I'm
going to define things informally just
using words. And if you have any
questions about what these mean
formally, you can ask and I'll be happy
to answer.
So, first, each player I is going to
play their component of A star until
someone deviates.
And then what happens?
If someone has deviated,
what does player I do?
Well,
if someone has deviated, we revert
to this Nash equilibrium.
So,
each player I
plays their component of that stage game
Nash equilibrium, right? AI
NE.
So, let's just see where we are here.
I've defined a strategy profile.
Let's just check if we follow this
strategy profile, indeed, we're going to
get A star every period. Because in the
first period, or in the zeroth period,
every player is going to play AI star,
and then in the next period, since no
one's deviated, every player plays AI
star, and then the next period, and the
next period, and so on. So, it's true
that if the players follow this strategy
profile, oh, I missed a Y.
If the players follow this strategy
profile, then indeed, A star is going to
be played every period, and therefore
the payoff we're going to get is V.
The issue is this may not be a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
So, we have to check that this strategy
profile actually constitutes a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium. And indeed,
it's not going to be a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium if the discount factor
delta is too low.
If the players are too impatient, this
is not going to work. So, what we need
to show is that as long as the players
are patient enough,
this strategy profile will indeed
constitute a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium. So, let's check that.
Any questions? I think I
This may seem a little abstract.
Okay?
So, let's go down here.
So, we want to check that this is a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
Or
in fact, it's only going to be a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium for delta large
enough. So, we'll check maybe whether
So, remember, whenever you're asked to
check whether something is an SPNE,
we always follow the same steps. We're
going to apply the one-shot deviation
principle. So, we're going to check if
any player has a profitable one-shot
deviation.
We have to do that at every single
history,
but in general, there's way too many
histories to look at. So, remember, the
key step is to group our histories.
And here, we naturally see two groups of
histories.
There's the histories where no one's
deviated, and the histories where
someone's deviated.
So, as usual, we're going to group our
histories
into
categories one and two.
And it's actually easier to start with
two, so let's start with two.
Someone has deviated.
And here, no one has deviated.
So, if someone has deviated, how are we
How are we supposed to play from here on
out under this strategy profile?
If someone has deviated, what we do is
we just play the stage game Nash
equilibrium every single period.
And we know that this must be an
equilibrium of this subgame because we
know that it's always in that a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium to just play
this the stage game Nash every period.
So, if someone has deviated, what we're
doing is we're playing A and E forever
after,
regardless of what people do in the
past.
Maybe I'll say no matter what. That's
the key.
Why do I say no matter what? Well,
if someone has deviated, we're supposed
to play the Nash equilibrium from here
on out. Once someone has deviated, that
can never change. Whatever we do
tomorrow, it's still the case that
someone has deviated, and therefore,
we're going to play the stage game Nash
equilibrium.
And we've already argued that
this has to be a subgame perfect
uh this has to be an equilibrium of the
stage game because there's no way you
can benefit by deviating from a Nash
equilibrium, and because future play is
independent of past play.
So, this is sort of the the easy case.
This is always going to work.
What if no one has deviated?
Well,
as usual, let's look at two things.
Let's suppose no one has deviated,
and let's focus on player I,
and let's compare what player I is
supposed to do to a one-shot deviation.
So, as we always say, we're going to say
what happens if they follow
the strategy profile, or if they choose
a one-shot deviation.
So, what happens if no one has deviated,
and player I follows the strategy
profile, and then everyone else follows
the strategy profile thereafter? What's
going to happen
uh
under this strategy profile?
Yeah. The payoff is going to be the that
factor V. It is. And And why Let's just
first say what the outcome's going to
be, and then we can talk about payoffs,
yeah? The outcome is that everyone is
playing
like whatever goes along with that
factor V.
Yeah, so we have it up here, right? A
star, right? That's the notation we
have, yeah. So, we're going to get A
star today, A star tomorrow, A star the
next day, and so on, right?
Now,
what happens if player I
chooses a one-shot deviation at this
history? Okay?
Well, before,
we were looking at games that only had
two actions. So, there was only one
possible deviation. Now, there's
actually a lot of different one-shot
deviations because player I could
deviate to any possible action in the
game. So, we have to be more precise.
Let's say a one-shot deviation, maybe
we'll call this
A I prime to show that it's a deviation.
So, let's look at what happens if at
this history,
player I deviates to A I prime today,
and then follows their strategy profile
their strategy forever after. Okay? So,
first, let's see what happens today.
Well, player I is choosing a unilateral
deviation. So, today, we're going to
have A I prime,
A
negative I star.
What does this mean? Everyone else is
still playing according to A star.
That's what they're supposed to do.
Player I is the only one who's deviated,
and they've deviated exactly to this
action A I prime.
Okay?
That's their one-shot deviation today.
There's a lot of different one-shot
deviations corresponding to different
choices of A I prime, and we're going to
have to make sure that none of those
deviations is profitable.
What happens
in the next period, then?
Yeah, in the front. The second history
group.
Uh yeah, so So, let's just say what is
the action profile here? The second
group is A and E.
Exactly. Now, we go to A and E, right?
Cuz we're playing Nash reversion.
Tomorrow, we say, "Wait, player I has
deviated.
From here on out, we're going to play
the the stage game Nash,
and we get A and E,
and dot dot dot.
So, now we see the classic trade-off.
Player I might potentially
maybe I'll say plus, they might benefit
today
because by choosing
action A I prime, they might strictly
increase their stage game payoff,
but by doing that, they're going to be
punished in the future.
I'm going to put a negative here.
How is this a punishment? Why do we know
that this is worse for player I than
this?
Yeah? Cuz we defined over here that the
I is strictly less. Exactly this, right?
This exactly tells us that if we revert
to the Nash equilibrium, that will be a
punishment for the player.
So, now, we'll go through the algebra in
a second, but we should just see pretty
intuitively if delta is high enough, and
the players are patient enough,
the one-shot gain from this deviation is
going to be outweighed by the forever
after loss that the players that the
player I is going to experience. So, we
can use the threat of punishing players
if they deviate to
discipline their behavior and prevent
them from deviating today from A star,
even though A star is not necessarily a
Nash equilibrium of the stage game.
Um
let's uh
actually write this difference out more
formally. So,
uh
let's look at
maybe
So, let's write down
the gain
for player I
from a one-shot deviation
to A I prime. It's a deviation, so it
can't be equal to A I star.
Right? Otherwise, it wouldn't be a
deviation.
Let's So, let's define this as delta I A
I prime.
This says, "If I'm player I, and I
follow this one-shot deviation, how much
do I gain?" A gain could be negative.
So, I'm just saying what is, you know,
gain, but gain could be positive or
negative. Uh well, let's look at it.
Well, we want to write out We just want
to look at all these payoff differences.
So, today, my gain is exactly this
difference. So, today, it's
U I
of A I prime
A negative I star
minus U I A I star.
Right? So, today, I get this instead of
this. So, my gain is this minus this.
Could be positive, could be negative,
but we're going to say that's the gain.
And then, forever after,
I get U I
this, right?
Now, it turns out that when we're
working with average payoffs, we get a
really there's some really simple
algebra here. So, first, I haven't put
the coefficients in front. This is what
happens today, right? So, if this is
what happens today, what needs to be in
front of this
if I'm interested in average discounted
payoff?
I don't know if we still have the
formula up here, but remember, with
average discounted payoff, we Yeah. 1
minus delta. 1 minus delta, exactly.
Okay.
Right? Because with average, it's 1
minus delta times 1 today, 1 minus delta
times delta tomorrow, 1 minus delta
times delta squared in the future.
>> [snorts]
>> And maybe this is a bit harder to see,
but
if this is what happens forever after,
it turns out that this is actually going
to be
just delta.
And one way to see this is that we're
working with average payoffs.
So, if this is how much weight we put on
what happens today,
then all the rest of the weight has to
be on what happens forever after.
But, if we want to formally see this,
let's write it down.
Well, this is
uh
Let's just see how we get this
coefficient.
So, where does this coefficient come
from?
Well, really it's
1 minus delta
times delta plus delta squared plus
delta cubed plus so.
Right?
How do we see this? Because this is the
gain I get tomorrow.
The gain I get tomorrow is multiplied by
1 minus delta up front, and then delta
to discount it for tomorrow.
Then the day after tomorrow is delta
squared. Then the day after that is
delta cubed and so on.
So, if I really write this out, it's
this gain I experience times this entire
sum.
Any questions on where I got this?
So, maybe to make it parallel, this is 1
minus delta times 1.
Right? So, what happens today is 1 minus
delta times the undiscounted value of 1.
What happens in the future is 1 minus
delta, but I have to discount it by
delta for tomorrow, delta squared, and
so on.
But, what is this
reduced to?
Well, this is actually
Let's write it. Let's just do a little
algebra. This is 1 minus delta
times delta
times 1. I'm just factoring out one
delta from here.
Then I get 1 plus delta plus delta
squared
so on.
But, this
is just 1 over 1 minus delta.
So, these cancel, and then I get delta.
So, if you follow the geometric series,
that's one way of thinking about it. The
other way of thinking about it is
whenever using delta and average
discounted payoffs, I put 1 minus delta
on today,
and delta on everything that happens
after today.
Um
And you can see here as delta gets close
to 1,
today is relatively unimportant relative
to the infinite future.
Let's be clear. It's always the case
that today matters more than tomorrow.
I'm not comparing today to tomorrow.
I'm comparing today to everything after
today. Tomorrow, the day after tomorrow,
the day after the day after tomorrow,
and so on.
Okay.
Well,
what do we know?
We know that this is negative.
Why?
Well,
our assumption over here.
We know that
what I get from the Nash equilibrium is
strictly worse than what I get under A
star.
So, if this is negative, I claim that
this is going to be less than or equal
to zero if delta is large enough.
Anyone walk me through why?
Why this is true?
In fact, it's going to be Maybe to make
it the argument clear, I'll say it's
strictly
Yeah.
I mean, if you make delta really large,
then the first term goes to zero.
Exactly, that's the argument. Whatever
this is, we don't really care what this
is. We just make delta really, really
big.
Then this is basically zero. So, this
whole term first term is basically zero.
But, then this term is negative, and if
if delta is close to 1, then we're
basically getting all of this negative
term. So, we're going to get something
strictly uh negative.
We could carefully write out the algebra
and find the exact bound, and and we're
done.
Okay.
But, really I guess what we've shown
is that for each player I,
and for each possible deviation A I
prime,
there's some delta large enough. Let me
say maybe delta greater than delta I of
A I prime.
So, really what this argument has shown
is I can choose some threshold. Maybe
I'll put a bar.
Delta I of of A I prime, so that if
delta is above this threshold, then this
particular one-shot deviation for player
I is not profitable.
So, how do I get
my threshold
delta bar from the theorem statement?
Right now, I have a lot of different
deltas, right? I have a different delta
for each player I and each deviation.
And I'm saying if delta is above that,
then this deviation is not profitable.
Yeah? Just take the maximum. Take the
maximum of all of these, right? So, what
I know is if delta is bigger than this
number, I know this particular deviation
is not profitable.
But, there's another deviation as well,
and I have to make sure that's not
profitable. But, that other deviation
also has some threshold delta. And if I
just make take the maximum of all these
thresholds, then if delta is larger than
the maximum of all these thresholds,
then it's definitely the case that none
of these is profitable. And here you can
see, if you're kind of mathematically
inclined, finiteness is playing an
important role here, because I can only
take the maximum over finitely many
things.
Um
Good.
So, this is the argument. Just
intuitively, take delta big enough, and
all of these deviations are going to be
unprofitable.
All right, let me So, that's the proof
of the Nash reversion folk theorem. Any
questions on on that?
Cool.
Excuse tired. Okay.
So, now let's do
go a little farther.
Uh
maybe I'll call it
Actually, I'm going to save some board
space. I'm just going to go straight to
here.
So, I'm going to look at now what I'll
call the individualized
Nash reversion folk theorem.
So, before, we just said we're going to
punish everyone by going to this Nash
equilibrium. Right? But, in general,
games often have multiple Nash
equilibria, and we saw with like the
Boston game that one Nash equilibrium
might be good for one player,
and a different Nash equilibrium might
be good for another player.
So, we don't actually need to punish
everyone with the same Nash equilibrium.
So, the idea of the individualized Nash
reversion folk theorem is that for each
player, we need some Nash equilibrium
that we'll use if that player deviates.
But, that might be a different Nash
equilibrium than what we use if another
player deviates.
So, now
let's say
Let's just rearrange this.
I mean, now maybe I'm erasing. I think
now at this point I might as well just
start from scratch.
Okay.
Let's say for each player I,
there exists
a Nash equilibrium
A N E
I of G.
So, this is an individualized Nash
equilibrium
such that
So, what does this tell me?
It says for every player I,
I can find some Nash equilibrium the
stage game. It could be the same Nash
equilibrium for everyone, but it doesn't
have to be,
such that that player I does worse under
this particular Nash equilibrium than
under V I.
So,
notice this is a weaker assumption
because
it may not be that there's a single Nash
equilibrium that satisfies this
property, but there may be different
Nash equilibria for different players.
There might be one Nash equilibrium for
player one that player one really
doesn't like, and a different Nash
equilibrium that player two doesn't
like.
And the idea is very simple. How do I
discourage player one from deviating? I
say if player one deviates, we're going
to play the Nash equilibrium that player
one doesn't like.
And if player two deviates, we're going
to play the Nash equilibrium that player
two doesn't like. And that way neither
player wants to deviate.
So, we're going to use individualized
punishments.
Um
So,
do I have Let's see.
Great.
So, here I think using the old board
will actually be helpful. Let's prove
the individualized uh
Nash reversion folk theorem.
Again, in the special case
that V equals U of A star for some
action profile A star.
So,
now we just need to change step two.
So, as before, we start by just playing
A star every period. But, now the
structure of the punishments are
different. And maybe I'll say to I.
So, IF PLAYER I DEVIATES,
WHAT DO WE DO?
WHICH NASH EQUILIBRIUM DO we
do we play?
Well, if player I deviates, we're going
to play this Nash equilibrium that
player I doesn't like.
So, maybe I'll say every player J
So, what does this mean?
The I here says it's the Nash
equilibrium that player I doesn't like.
And that in itself is a strategy is an
action profile.
So, player J is going to play player J's
component of the Nash equilibrium that
player I doesn't like.
And then the same argument's going to go
through because when player I
contemplates a unilateral one-shot
deviation, they recognize that if they
deviate, they're going to get punished
with their own personalized Nash
equilibrium forever.
And if they're patient enough, they're
going to be deterred by that.
Uh
there's a few issues here though. We
have to be careful.
We have to define this a little
more carefully. So,
what happens if a player deviates and
then and then another player deviates?
What do we do?
Right? We have to be kind of careful
about that.
And it turns out the trick is
um
you only look at who deviated first.
Once there's one deviation, we use that
punishment forever. So, if I want to be
more precise, I'll say
instead of if player I deviates,
I'll say
if there has been a deviation,
there's been some deviation,
and the first player to deviate was
player I.
So, if I look back in the history, it
could be that there are many, many
different deviations.
But all I'm going to say is where was
the first deviation and who did it?
And player I
deviated first.
Then, this is what we play.
So, we're getting close. I'd argue
there's still a little imprecision here.
What What could go wrong? What's the one
issue with this uh definition? I said I
look back. So, how do we play? We look
back. We see if anyone's deviated, and
then we see who deviated first.
And then we punish that person.
But what's What could go wrong here?
How do we know who deviated first?
What if two people deviated at the same
time?
What if in the in the zeroth period, two
players deviate?
Now we're in period one, we look back.
We say both people players deviated at
the same time, who do we punish?
Any thoughts?
Yeah? Randomly choose which one? You
could randomly choose. That would be one
thing. So, if let's say two players
deviated simultaneously first, then half
the time I'll punish one and half the
time I'll punish another.
That's a great idea. That's one thing
that could work. It turns out it doesn't
even matter what you do.
Um
as long as you play some Nash
equilibrium.
Uh and the reason is that
no one can unilaterally
cause two people to deviate.
So, when players are contemplating
whether they should unilaterally
deviate,
they don't ever take into account what
happens if two players deviate at once.
But I think your suggestion is the
easiest one. So,
um
we'll say over here
note or randomize
if two players deviate simultaneously.
So, under this strategy, we just each
play A star until we see someone's
deviated. We look who that person is. We
play the Nash equilibrium that's bad for
that player, and then we just play that
Nash equilibrium forever out forever
after, regardless of what happens again.
Someone else might deviate. Who cares?
We just stick with our Nash equilibrium.
And because it's a Nash equilibrium, you
can check that no one has incentive to
deviate.
Or if I'll say if more than one, there
could be many players deviate
simultaneously.
Any questions about this?
Okay, so now we're going to go to the
final
folk theorem, sort of the
the deepest folk theorem, I guess.
And this is really what was in
that paper from 1986.
And the question is
can we use
harsher punishments than Nash
equilibrium?
So, so far, the way we've always
punished players for deviating is by
reverting to Nash.
Either we revert to the same stage game
Nash equilibrium, regardless of who
deviated,
or we revert to an individualized Nash
equilibrium that depends on the identity
of the deviator.
But the question is, can we punish even
more harshly than Nash equilibrium? And
indeed, there are some games where we
want to do that. We talked about in
Cournot, the way that we often see
punishments is that one player floods
the market.
One player produces a lot of goods to
bring down the market price.
But that in itself is not a Nash
equilibrium because that player is doing
really badly
uh as well.
So, the question is, how can we use
harsher punishments?
And
here's the challenge.
Okay?
What was nice is if the punishments were
themselves Nash equilibria, then the
punishments were self-enforcing.
Once we went to that punishment, no one
wanted to deviate. But the challenge is
who punishes the punisher?
for deviating.
The problem is if you want to impose a
really harsh punishment, let's say
player one wants to really punish player
two, that punishment might be really
costly for player one.
But that means player one might not want
to actually carry out their punishment.
So, we have to make sure that we punish
the punisher if they don't actually
carry out the punishment.
But now we're getting into this infinite
regress. Whoever's punishing the
punisher, they might not want to carry
out that punishment because that might
hurt themselves. So, we have to have a
way to punish the punisher
the the person who punishes the
punisher, and then you see we we get
into difficulty. So, it's hard. What we
want to do is we want to say player one,
we don't want you to deviate because if
you do, player two is going to punish
you.
But then we have to say and if player
two doesn't punish you as she's supposed
to, then another player is going to
punish player two. And then we're going
to get into these cycles. So, it's going
to be quite tricky. And I think for a
while, this is why
it took, you know, people a long time to
figure this out. How can we
figure out these punishments?
Uh
and it turns out the kind of solution, I
guess the simple solution,
is that we want to do kind of two things
at once.
Our our strategy is going to have kind
of two components.
The first component is we punish
deviations.
If someone deviates,
the other players punish them. That's
easy.
But then,
we, instead of thinking about punishing
the punisher for not carrying out the
punishment, the trick is actually to
reward the punisher for carrying out the
punishment.
Uh
So, the general structure is if anyone
deviates, everyone else punishes them.
And then if those people actually
punishes they're supposed to, then we
reward the people for punishing.
And this is kind of a high-level idea of
of how we approach it. And let's go
a little more formally.
So, to be a little more formal,
we want to say, well, what is the
harshest punishment?
Say on player I.
So, let's say player I has deviated. We
want to punish them.
What's the harshest way
we can punish player I?
Well,
intuitively,
players
we want to choose
a negative of I.
So, A negative I, these are the actions
of everyone but player I. We want to
choose A negative I
to make
player I
as worse off, you know, worse off.
But this is kind of tricky because
how bad is this for player I? Well, it
depends what player I does.
Right?
So, we have to think what's the worst
way to punish player I.
We as players other than player I are
going to choose this action profile.
But, we don't know how bad this is
because it depends how player I
responds.
But, the trick is to say, well, let's
suppose player I responds optimally.
So, let's say we choose a negative I,
and then player I chooses the action
that's best for him given a negative I.
We want to make that as bad as possible.
So, let's
So,
let's say we choose a negative I.
How much can this hurt player I? Well,
player I can get the max
over AI
of UI of AI A negative I.
Right?
So, this is the punishment.
Everyone other than I is trying to
punish player I.
But, player I is saying, well, if this
is what you're how you're punishing me,
I'm going to choose my action to make my
payoff as high as possible.
So, we can think of this number as
representing
the strength of the punishment.
So,
let's think of this
as kind of the
maybe the severity
of A negative I
as a punishment.
The lower this is, the more severe the
punishment.
So, any ideas here? How can we make this
punishment
as bad as possible?
Well, if this is the severity
of this punishment, let's just make this
payoff as low as possible.
So, the trick
is to now take the minimum
over A negative I.
Let's go through this slowly cuz I think
this is a bit tricky.
If we choose a negative I, this is how
well player I can do.
By minimizing over this, we're choosing
the worst possible punishment. We're
choosing the action profile so that even
when player I plays optimally,
their payoff is as low as possible.
And we're going to need a word for this.
This is going to be VI lower bar.
This is basically the worst possible
punishment we can impose on player I.
And this is called the
pure
minimax value.
So, this is often called minmaxing
player I.
It means everyone else gets together
and chooses the action that makes player
I as, you know, player I's payoff as low
as possible assuming that player I best
responds to this punishment.
So, now we can state the final
version of the folk theorem. Maybe I'll
put it here.
And then we'll conclude.
So, this is maybe called the pure
minimax
folk theorem.
And in the Nash version folk theorem, we
just had to make sure we could punish
player I by reverting to the Nash
equilibrium.
Here, we're going to make sure we can
punish player I by using the worst
possible punishment. So, the condition,
the assumption
is simply going to be
that VI is greater than VI lower bar
for all players I.
And it turns out that this assumption is
weaker than all of the other
assumptions, and as a result, this
version of the minmax of the folk
theorem is stronger.
There's a larger range of Vs that
satisfy this condition. Because VI may
not in this case be higher than any Nash
equilibrium payoff, but it is higher
than this worst possible punishment over
here.
It turns out we need one technical
condition. So, I'll write this sort of
in parentheses.
And V of G, remember V of G is the set
of feasible payoff vectors, um
has full rank.
Uh this is a technical assumption that
uh
it's fine. It's not covered. It's not
going to be tested. I just don't want to
write something wrong and get uh have
people complaining. So, there is one
assumption we
And this comes from the paper from 1986.
So, now we're really getting to kind of
the frontier. Um and let me just give
you a really simple
outline
of the proof kind of following what we
described.
So,
the proof sketch now there's going to be
three stages.
So, initially,
everyone's going to play
Maybe I'll just write it a bit more
simply.
We play A star.
Remember, A star as usual is going to be
the action profile that gives us the
payoff vector V.
We're going to play A star until a
deviation.
And then we have to specify what happens
if player I deviates.
And it turns out there's going to be two
components of this.
You might say, oh, if player I deviates,
then we're just going to impose the
worst possible punishment on player I
forever.
But, the problem is people might not
want to carry out that punishment
because it may be very costly for them
to punish. Remember, we have to also
reward the punishers. So, the trick is
we
kind of minmax
player I
for N periods.
And then,
if we get through this stage, we reward
everyone
for actually carrying out the
punishment.
forever after.
But, the structure of this is a little
more complicated.
So,
first we play A star.
Then, we're going to minmax, meaning
impose the harshest possible punishment
on player I for N periods.
And then, if we actually carry that out,
we reward the punishers forever after.
But, if at any stage any player
deviates,
we go back to the beginning of stage 2I.
So, if player J deviates at any point,
now we minmax player J for N periods and
then reward the punishers.
If any of the punishers deviate, we go
back to the beginning of that for that
corresponding punisher. So, if at any
stage, and I'm not going to write this
on the board, but I'll just say it in
words, if at any stage of this strategy
profile a player deviates,
we start this sequence for that player.
We minmax them for N periods and then we
reward the players for carrying out that
punishment. And if someone else
deviates, we go back and do it again. Uh
and this is a much more complicated
structure.
Uh you know,
people who are still professors at MIT
came up with this and, you know, uh this
is sort of we're getting to the frontier
here. And uh and this is much harder to
to deal with. But, let me So, I'll sort
of say I wouldn't expect you to be able
to
fully understand this proof on an exam,
but um we may ask I may ask a little bit
about it on on a problem set.
So, let me stop there, and uh I will see
everyone on Thursday.